Integration ist ja so unendlich viel
mehr als einfach ein Bett und ein Dach
über dem Kopf und irgendwie eine
Unterkunft und und essen und trinken
sondern dann in der Folge so unendlich
viel mehr freie sie haben richtig Prügel
bekommen aber auch Zustimmung bekommen
viel Zustimmung auch bekommen
weil es etwas fundamentales ist wo sie
daran gehen wollen sie sagen dass
individuelle Recht auf Asyl sollten wir
abschaffen
warum
weil ich auf der Suche nach Lösungen war
und bin und weil ich der Auffassung bin
dass der Status Quo wie wir ihn haben
total unbefriedigend ist und zwar für
alle Beteiligten da gibt's zum einen die
aufnahmegesellschaften in Europa die
überfordert sind über ganz weite
Strecken hinweg
starr an Start gilt für Deutschland gilt
auch für andere europäische Staaten die
die Kontrolle über das
Migrationsgeschehen vollkommen verloren
haben und auf der anderen Seite tun wir
so als hätten wir in Höchst humanes
migrationsrecht haben wir aber nicht wir
haben die Situation dass in den letzten
zehn Jahren etwa
viele Menschen im Mittelmeer ertrunken
sind genauso viele auf dem Weg zum
Mittelmeer in der in der Sahara
beispielsweise das ist eine Situation
die ist unerträglich und deswegen müssen
wir daran etwas ändern Ich will übrigens
mal ein Beispiel nehmen das gar nicht
von mir selbst kommt sondern von der
migrationswissenschaftler der diese die
der diese Situation sehr gut auf den
Punkt bringt wir haben derzeit ein
Rechtssystem im Bereich der Migration wo
wir ein starkes Recht in Schaufenster
stellen und gleichzeitig alles Mögliche
tun damit es nicht wahrgenommen werden
kann und gutes Beispiel dafür ist eine
syrische Familie
die sehr wahrscheinlich
aufnahmeberechtigt ist in Deutschland
und da könnten wir ja auch sagen die
können von Beirut nach Berlin mit einem
One-Way Ticket für 200 Euro pro Person
fliegen und dann hier Schutz bekommen
tun wir aber nicht wir verlangen von
ihnen dass sie Asyl bei uns in
Deutschland bzw auf europäischen Grund
beantragen und das bedeutet dass Sie
sich auf diesen gefährlichen Weg nach
Europa machen dass sie sich kriminellen
Schleppern anvertrauen dass sie dafür
nicht 200 € sondern 10.000 € aufwenden
um hierher zu kommen und damit machen
wir eine Selektion zu uns kommen nicht
die die am schutzbedürftigsten sind zu
uns kommen die die jungen kräftig gesund
und auch leistungsfähig genug sind diese
Kriminellen Schlepper zu bezahlen und
das finde ich einen total unbefriedigend
dazu Zustand und ausgehend von dem finde
ich ist es jedenfalls jede Mühe wert
sich zu überlegen wie man das besser
gestalten kann und zwar für die
Aufnahmegesellschaft genauso wie die
Frage zu beantworten wie kommen wir
unsere humanitären Verantwortung nach
ich schaue gerade mal hier so in die
Runde Frau kohlenberger was geht Ihnen
durch den Kopf wenn sie das Hören ich
will es nur um einen Kontext stellen wir
wären das erste europäische Land dass
das macht und ich glaube das ist auch
guckt zu Michael Brücker das braucht
Grummeln dass viele so haben auch in
ihrer Fraktion übrigens
ausgerechnet Deutschland auch mit der
Geschichte
ausgerechnet wir werden werden denn die
ersten die das machen die wirklich das
Individualrecht auf Asyl abschaffen und
kassieren ich würde ein bisschen
korrigieren ja formal wäre es
tatsächlich das erste europame und das
ist ja auch und das haben sie jetzt ein
wenig ausgeklammert in der Skizze wo ich
in großen Teilen sogar mitgeben mit
dieser Probleme Analyse ein ganz großes
Thema ein großes Problem beim jetzigen
europäischen Migration sondern System
ist dass wir viele geltende Regeln haben
die nicht mehr umgesetzt werden in
einigen Mitgliedstaaten allen voran
Ungarn wo de facto-recht ausgesetzt
wurde aber auch Griechenland Polen und
so weiter und vor allem und das ist
glaube ich eine wichtige Ableitung
gerade für Deutschland und auch für Sie
wo Sie mit dieser Idee dass Asylrecht
abzuschaffen spielen ich glaube es kommt
nicht von ungefähr das in Polen und
Ungarn die Rechte von Schutzsuchenden
mit Füßen getreten werden und
gleichzeitig auch die rechte
etablierterer Gruppen in der
Gesellschaft beschnitten wurden in Polen
die rechte die reproduktiven Rechte von
Frauen in Ungarn ist das Mediensystem
unter Druck das Justizsystem und unter
Druck und so weiter und wir wissen
einfach dass die Beschneidung von
Minderheitenrechten die Beschneidung der
Rechte von marginalisierten in unserer
Gesellschaft sehr häufig das
einfallsdauer bilden um auch andere
etablierte Rechte zu beschneiden das nur
um den großen Rahmen aufzumachen wo ich
noch kurz ins Konkrete gehen möchte ja
ich stimme den ganz so bei der
Problemanalyse sie haben das sehr
richtig aufgeschlüsselt ja das jetzige
Asylsystem auf europäischer Ebene
existiert betreibt eine ökonomische
Selektion wer sich leisten kann von
Damaskus beispielsweise nach Berlin zu
gehen wie auch immer der kann kommen die
Ärmsten der Armen sind stuck and plays
also die sind dort vor Ort angekettet im
metaphorischen Sinne wir betreiben auch
eine demografische Selektion die wir
noch verschärfen durch die grenzgewalt
entlang der Balkanroute pushbacks auf
der Mittelmeer und so weiter also da
wird die Selektion noch vorangetrieben
es ist sehr wichtig wir brauchen mehr
legale reguläre Zugangswege aber
komplementär das heißt das was Sie
gesagt haben komplementär bedeutet
zusätzlich genau das was sie richtig
gesagt haben wir ermöglichen einer
syrischen Familie aus der maskus
beispielsweise einfach ins Flugzeug zu
steigen sich diesen gefährlichen teuren
Fluchtweg zu ersparen und direkt in
Berlin anzukommen finde ich sehr gut
aber es gibt eben auch Personen
Individuen für die das nicht in Frage
kommen würde die nämlich bei so einem
kontingentlösung wie sie vor zu sagen ja
durch das Netz fallen und das ist das
Problematische daran nein also
die Idee ist nicht dass die gesamte
syrische Bevölkerung ins Flugzeug steigt
und hierher kommt sondern sie sagen wir
wollen das kontingentieren ich sage ja
nur ich habe den Irrsinn beschrieben
sozusagen
weil sie die Frau Kohlberger
entsprechend gefragt haben also ich
adressiere nicht Deutschland mit meinem
Vorschlag und zwar einfach weil das und
im Bereich des migrationsrechts keine
Relevanz hätte wenn Sie den Artikel 16A
unseres Grundgesetzes anschauen dann ist
der relevant für 0,8 % der Schutz
suchenden in Deutschland und da muss man
einfach sagen seit dem Jahr 1993 wo wir
die letzte große Partei übergreifende
Reform an diesem Artikel 16A das
Grundgesetzes gemacht haben kann ja
niemand der auf dem Landweg nach
Deutschland kommt dieses Asylrecht
beanspruchen weil er kommt ja durch ein
anderes europäisches Land der kommt
durch ein anderes sicheres Land und
deswegen geht es nicht das heißt mein
Ansatz ist der dass wir das nur auf
europäischer Ebene machen können das
heißt man müsste die
asylverfahrensrichtlinie ändern darüber
wird jetzt ohnehin seit acht Jahren
bereits diskutiert das ist der richtige
Ansatzpunkt und deswegen geht es um eine
gemeinsame europäische Lösung und auch
darum dass wir hier ein gemeinsamen Weg
finden und den möchte ich so finden dass
wir kein Minus ein humanitärer Aufnahme
haben mein Vorschlag ist der der dass
wir in Europa zwischen 300 und 400.000
Menschen das war mein Vorschlag Europa
in Europa das wäre aber das was Europa
in den letzten 10 Jahren
jahresdurchschnittlich aufgenommen
und im ersten Halbjahr nur im ersten
Halbjahr 23 ne über
519.000 Anträge in der EU ja in diesem
Jahr
ganz kurz um die Zahlen klar zu haben
also über eine halbe Million gegenüber
dem Vorjahreszeitraum haben wir eine
Steigerung von knapp 80% auf 78%, 70 %
und wenn Sie das jetzt 188 januar und
wenn sie 180 hochrechnet weil wir wissen
ja wenn man sich die Jahresscheiben
anschaut die Monate September Oktober
November sind die migrationsintensivsten
kann man davon ausgehen dass es dieses
Jahr 350.000 Asylanträge in Deutschland
geben wird und das ist natürlich nicht
wir müssen sagen jemand der diesen
Antrag stellt selbst wenn er abgelehnt
wird bleibt trotzdem hier absolut wir
haben im Grunde oder die Koalition die
Koalition hat ja in den vergangenen
Monaten weiteres unternommen dass das so
bleibt seit
Dezember letzten Jahres haben wir das
Chancen Aufenthaltsgesetz das dann eben
auch den Spurwechsel ermöglicht selbst
für diejenigen die ihre Identität nicht
offenbart haben also im Grunde genommen
wird das Signal ausgesendet wenn du es
mal nach Deutschland geschafft hast dann
kannst du hier bleiben und zwar
unabhängig von der Frage ob du
schutzbedürftig bist oder nicht
also erstens mal würden sie das mit der
Abschaffung des Asylrechts nicht ändern
ich möchte aber gern einmal noch den
Bogen ein wenig erweiterne fokussieren
uns sehr auf Europa
auf den Weg machen sehr viele
migrationsexperten tatsächlich dass er
das abschiebeverbot dieses nicht
zurückweisungsprinzip dass ein
Kernprinzip der Genfer
Flüchtlingskonvention ist und auch in
europäischen Grundrechte Charter
verankert ist dass das ja dadurch nicht
einfach abgeschafft würde das heißt wir
hätten dann sehr wahrscheinlich die
Situation dass Menschen kommen hier zwar
nicht um asylan suchen dürfen aber auch
nicht abgeschoben werden können weil
ihnen im jeweiligen Herkunftsland wo es
vielleicht kein Kontingent ihre Aufnahme
gibt Verfolgung
Menschenrechtsverletzung selbst starke
ökonomische Reparation drohen und dann
kann man die Menschen nicht
zurückstellen also ist eine große Lücke
ich möchte aber noch eines anmerken weil
die fokussieren uns sehr stark also
absolut ist es natürlich nicht wissen
schreiben selbstverständlich ich möchte
noch eines anmerken wir fokussieren uns
immer auch sehr auf die Frage wie stark
ist Europa belastet was Schulter oder
Europa und innerhalb Europas Deutschland
sehr richtig aber um einmal ein bisschen
raus zu zoomen ich glaube gerade in
Zeiten wie diesen tut uns der Blick über
den europäischen Tellerrand sehr gut 90%
aller geflüchteten weltweit finden nicht
den Industriestaaten Zuflucht sondern in
Entwicklungs- und Schwellenländern und
das sind vor allem unmittelbare
Nachbarländer von den fruchtländern in
Libanon in Jordanien ist jeder vierte
bis jeder 600 lebende Menschen und das
was sie machen würden wenn sie sagen
Europa sagt kein Asylrecht mehr oder wie
auch immer das würde was würde das denn
bedeuten für den globalen Süden die
sollen dann weiterhin für Aufnahme
sorgen und wir selber putzen uns ab ich
glaube das ist wirklich wirklich sehr
sehr schwierig weil damit würde man eine
Kettenreaktion auslösen die fatales zur
Folge hätte für den global das würde ich
wirklich bestreiten und zwar zwei Punkte
erstens mal Deutschland ist es
viertgrößte Aufnahme Land der Welt
und wie sie richtigerweise beschrieben
haben die ersten drei in dieser Liste
zum Beispiel Afghanistan Bolivien das
sind Länder die Menschen aus der
unmittelbaren Nachbarschaft aufnehmen
das machen wir übrigens auch und das ist
auch meine These dass wenn aus einem
Land jemand kommt das unmittelbarer
Nachbar der Europäischen Union ist weil
dort politische Verfolgung ist wie
vielleicht für manche in der Türkei oder
Krieg ist wie in der Ukraine dann nehmen
wir diese Menschen auf das ist
selbstverständlich weil wir dann das
nächste sichere Land oder der nächste
die als die EU sozusagen der nächste
sichere Hafen ist wir haben letztes Jahr
1,2 Millionen Menschen aus der Ukraine
aufgenommen da sage ich überhaupt nichts
dazu sondern das ist selbstverständlich
diese Menschen fliehen vor dem Krieg und
die nehmen wir auf dem Platz bitte nein
also es war Platz bitte diese These
finde ich auch unverantwortlich wir
haben eine Situation wo der Deutsche
Städtetag sagt bei uns fehlen 700 1000
Wohnungen bei uns fehlen 400.000
Kitaplätze
25.000 Lehrerstellen sind nicht besetzt
ich komme aus dem ländlichen Raum der
ist auch die Versorgung mit
niedergelassenen Ärzten schwierig das
ist glaube ich auch in anderen Teilen
Deutschlands der Fall also eine
Situation wo wir eine Infrastruktur
hätten die beliebig anpassbar wäre diese
Situation haben wir definitiv nicht und
das führt dazu dass eben viele in der
Gesellschaft in den Städten und
Gemeinden tatsächlich ein
überlastungsgefühl hat ich will ihnen
Beispiel nehmen wenn sie
integrations- und Sprachkurse anbieten
das ist ja das Wichtigste weil es eben
nicht nur um Bett und rot geht ja und
sie warten darauf ein Jahr dann ist es
viel zu spät dann kann Integration fast
nicht gelingen und übrigens das dauert
nicht deshalb ein Jahr weil das Geld
nicht zur Verfügung gestellt wurde das
dauert deshalb so lange weil sie die
Personen haben das Personal machen
Entschuldigung Frau kohlenberger oder
vielleicht frage ich Sie
was würden Sie denn vorschlagen wenn man
wenn man sich diese Bilder mal anschaut
ich habe mich dieser Tage mal mit
Lampedusa beschäftigt meine da gibt es
dieses dieses Zentrum das hat glaube ich
Platz für 400 Menschen da kommen an
manchen Tagen sieben tausend Menschen an
60 70 Boote an einem einzigen Tag das
sind hier so fürchterliche Bilder die
wir da gerade sehen
ich meine das ist nicht zu bewältigen
schlicht und ergreifend dieses Land frei
hat ja gerade finde ich zutreffend
beschrieben tut sich mittlerweile schwer
was die Infrastruktur angeht natürlich
kriegt man viele Leute irgendwie
irgendwo unter aber dann sitzen hier
grüne Landräte das Rassismus völlig
unverdächtig ja sondern eher auf der
anderen Seite zu Hause die sagen tut mir
leid auch was die Linie meiner Partei
ist aber das können wir so schlicht und
ergreifen dich bei bewältigen also was
ist zu tun und ich habe das Gefühl auch
wenn man sich zum Beispiel die
Fluchtbewegungen von Gambia aus über die
auf die Kanarischen Inseln und dann
andere Orte hinschaut
man dann teilweise es dann nicht schafft
richtig zu navigieren dann dann kommen
irgendwelche Boote in der Karibik an mit
lauter toten Menschen drin wollen wir
das das kann doch so nicht weitergehen
ich habe das Gefühl das ganze System
implodiert ich gebe dann absolut recht
ja und ich möchte aber auch darauf
hinweisen dass das Endprodukt dessen ist
was wir seit 2015 eigentlich schon lange
davor als dies Strategie Europas
anwenden nämlich Abschottung
abschreckungen Auslagerung und wenn
dieses Rezept denn so tauglich gewesen
wäre warum diskutieren wir gerade jetzt
wieder so hohe Ankunftszeiten also ich
möchte mal die Grundsatzfrage stellen
und ich glaube in dem was sie zuletzt
gesagt haben steckt ein Teil der Lösung
nämlich die Frage wie können wir
Regularität reguläre Migration sowohl
Flucht Migration als auch
Arbeitsmigration erhöhen und
gleichzeitig ihre reguläre Migration
senken ich glaube das ist die einzige
Möglichkeit um bis zu einem gewissen
gerade eine Steuerungen das System
ich habe jetzt die ganze Zeit über human
Migration gesprochen
unabhängig davon ist es natürlich
notwendig dass wir Arbeitskräfte
Migration brauchen aber die folgt ganz
anderen Regeln die humanitäre Migration
da geht es darum dass wir anderen
Menschen helfen die Schutz suchen im
Bereich der Fachkräfte Migration geht es
darum wen braucht unser Arbeitsmarkt und
da gibt es Regeln Fachkräfte
Einwanderung wenn sie mich ausreden
hätten lassen hätte ich das gerne
skizziert aber wir haben derzeit de
facto wirklich ein Problem da stimme ich
Ihnen so dass derzeit nicht wenige
Personen immer so ein System sind die
dort nicht hingehören und dort auch gar
nicht hin wollen das sind Menschen die
eigentlich Arbeitsmigranten wären die
aber keine legalen Zugangswege haben aus
Länder natürlich das Hara ist es fast
unmöglich legal nach Europa einzureisen
die Visa Antragstellung ist
unverhältnismäßig teuer und selten wird
sie positiv beschieden und so weiter und
sofort sehr sehr viele würden diese
Menschen werden aber auch und das zeigt
ein Blick zum Beispiel in Spaniens
erntefamen und so weiter benötigt weil
der größte Fachkräftemangel der größte
Arbeitskräftemangel herrscht nicht in
den akademischen Berufen sondern auch im
niedrigen mittelqualifizierten Bereich
ich gebe Ihnen Recht das sind nicht eins
zu eins die Menschen die wir uns gerne
aussuchen wollen das ist richtig aber
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob wir
angesichts dieser sich erst anbahnenden
demografischen Krise wirklich noch den
Luxus haben uns die Menschen auszusuchen
oder zu sagen man versucht dieses
Systeme zu entwirren nämlich so dass das
Asylsystem wirklich frei wird für
Menschen die Schutzbedarf haben aber
gleichzeitig auch mehr und angepasste
auf Bedürfnisse des Ziellandes und der
ankommenden abgegeben
ich glaube die Kollegen aus der Regie
haben das Plakat vorliegen ein Plakat
aus Österreich da können wir das einmal
ganz kurz zeigen meine die politischen
Folgen davon sind genau die das ist wer
ist das hier von wem ist das von
der FPÖ so weil ich das Entnehmen die
freiheitliche Jugend also Parteien sind
entspannt mich so sehr
wie kommt sowas in Österreich an
ich glaube das liegt vor allem daran
dass nicht wenige politische Akteure
nicht die Lösung suchen sondern das
Problem brauchen man braucht diese
Bilder wir hatten ja auch eine Aussage
unseres ehemaligen Bundeskanzler
Sebastian Kurz der gesagt hat wir werden
uns an hässliche Bilder gewöhnen müssen
ich befürchte wir haben das getan wir
haben uns an die hässlichen Bilder
gewöhnt und damit das migrationsthema
vor allem Thema ist leider ein Thema
womit sich sehr gut Stimmung machen
lässt und ich meine auch tatsächlich
dass ihnen wohl auch bewusst war durch
diese Aussage Asylrecht abschaffen das
war vor kurzem wiedergegeben ist mir
bewusst das war ja nicht nur ein Signal
an potentiell ankommendes und ich glaube
das ist immer auch ein Signal an die
eigene Bevölkerung zu zeigen wir zeigen
hat bekannte wir steigen auf der Syrien
mit dem Kopf ich finde das wirklich
schwierig weil sie einerseits ja jetzt
auch keinen Lösungsvorschlag gemacht
haben
aber wie genau konkret es funktioniert
ja nicht wir hatten
diversifizierte schaffen ja also bei
Arbeitsmigration würde ich ganz
passgenaue wir haben Instrumente wie
zirkuläre Migration komplementäre Pfade
wo man sich aussuchen kann Menschen die
Qualifikationen mitbringen aus
humanitären Krisensituationen zu holen
also wirklich zusammen zu denken da gibt
es gute Konzepte auch das Uhren HCR es
gibt ganz unterschiedliche möge
Möglichkeiten wie settlement
aufzustocken Botschaft zu Asyl wieder zu
reaktivieren also ich könnte ihnen
sozusagen
Ordnung ins System bringen mehr
Regularität mehr Struktur und dadurch
eben genau diese Bilder von Chaos und
Kontrollverlust verhindern
ganz am Anfang gesagt die
kontingentlösung von den frei ist
deswegen auch keine weil trotzdem
diejenigen die an der Botschaft ist Asyl
nicht bekommen können sich auf den Weg
machen werden wenn ihre These also
stimmt das Kontingentierung legale Wege
nur ein Weg sind aber auf der anderen
Seite trotzdem die Menschen sich auf den
Weg machen werden auch die
vermeintlich keine schutzquote bekommen
dann haben wir das Problem ja immer noch
nicht gelöst und wir werden eine Lösung
dann an den EU-Außengrenzen finden
müssen über die wollten wir sechs Jahre
lang nicht diskutieren ich bin auch
nicht der Meinung dass Deutschland ein
schlechtes Gewissen haben müsste was wir
seit sechs Jahren aufnehmen sowohl
finanziell als auch personell wir haben
immer noch nicht das Thema gelöst dass
die EU-Außengrenzen nicht geschützt sind
und dass alle durchgeleitet werden
teilweise ja wie der Bundespolizei Chef
neulich gesagt hat in einer
Taxiunternehmen von den Grenzen dann zur
nächsten Flüchtlingsunterkunft gebracht
wird wo auf jeden Fall jeder der Asyl
sagt dann hier bleiben kann weil ja auch
diejenigen die abgelehnt werden nicht
nur finanziell weiter unterstützt werden
sondern auch defacto einfach nicht
zurückgeführt werden das führt dazu dass
in Deutschland die Menschen das Gefühl
haben der recht statt gilt in diesem
Fall schlicht nicht mehr warum können
wir jetzt analysieren aber er gilt nicht
mehr bei dem Teilbereich wo es
vielleicht in Richtung Rückführung gehen
würde und wenn wir das Thema nicht lösen
dann brauchen wir über
kontingentierungen reguläre Migration
und Botschafter Asyl gar nicht reden
weil wir müssen das das lösen was die
Menschen umtreibt und leider solche
ekelhaften Parteien nach oben spielt mit
gern noch mal ein letztes Argument
machen Frau Kohlberger sie sagten vorhin
dass das funktioniert nicht man kann
sozusagen nicht die Botschaft aussenden
in diesem Land
gibt es sozusagen keinen keine
Bereitschaft mehr Menschen aufzunehmen
die skandinavischen Länder und
eigentlich fast alle Länder um uns herum
haben genau diesen diese Kehrtwende
gemacht die Schweden waren mal auf Platz
1 sie haben zwar 15 glaube ich
proportional zu Bevölkerung noch mehr
Menschen aufgenommen als Deutschland
weil ich das richtig im Kopf habe sind
mittlerweile ganz weit hinten Platz 16
17 18 die denen sein das hat sich
offenbar rumgesprochen
mit der Konsequenz das ist den Druck auf
Deutschland sozusagen die die letzte
Insel der Seligen wenn man so will in
Europa noch ein weiteres Mal erhöht hat
und wenn man sich mal die die die
Umfrage Ergebnisse auch der AFD anschaut
wenn man sich anschaut Blick auf die
kommenden Landtagswahlen im nächsten
Jahr in Sachsen in Thüringen und so
weiter dann kann dann das Gefühl
beschleichen da gibt es durchaus und
sehr wohl ein Zusammenhang wie gehen wir
damit also ich glaube das ist eine
grundsätzliche Frage tatsächlich nämlich
ist es die Ankunft fremder ich fand
dieses bewusst sehr allgemein die dafür
sorgt dass die AFD mehr zustuch bekommt
oder ist es die Art und Weise wieder
darüber gesprochen wird die Bilder die
gezeigt werden und die Tatsache dass
gerade Parteien in der Mitte Positionen
der rechten übernehmen und dadurch
normalisieren das Leid an den Grenzen
und auch die Entrechtung von
geflüchteten an den Grenzen wird immer
mehr normalisiert indem gerade Parteien
der Mitte versuchen vermeintlich den
rechten das Wasser abzugraben und
dadurch wird genau das normal ist
ich spreche ganz ganz allgemein
Punkt ja die die CDU sozusagen ist
schuld an Aufstieg der AFD ja dass man
sozusagen nur die Themen anderer
Parteien antizipieren zu dürfen zu
dürfen das was sie gesagt hat mich sehr
sehr wichtig wir haben auch einen
Fachausdruck dafür nämlich Wettbewerb
nach unten ja das sozusagen einzelne
Länder sich aus der Verantwortung ziehen
ich habe eingangs auch erwähnen in
Ungarn ist dass es vielleicht der Faktor
ausgesetzt und das ist eine
Kettenreaktion die sich da abzeichnet
und wo führt uns das denn hin zu Ende
gedacht im globalen Flüchtlingsschutz
und ich glaube schon dass man da erstens
einmal nicht nur aus Deutschland sondern
als Europa eine Verantwortung hat sie
haben richtigerweise gesagt deutsche
Staatsbürger glauben nicht mehr dass der
Rechtsstaat hier gilt oder befürchten
gilt nicht mehr er gilt schon längst
nicht mehr an der Peripherie Europas da
ist ein Gürtel der Gewalt der eingesetzt
hat und das ist auch unser Europa das
zählt zu Europa und wir wissen einfach
diese Gewalt an den Grenzen die greift
zunehmend nach innen aus das führt zu
Veron der gesamten Gesellschaft ich habe
Anfang skizziert auch wie
Rechtsstaatlichkeit Kris lesen auf
anderen Ebenen sich abzeichnen und ich
glaube schon dass es wesentlich wäre
sich auf diese Kernwerte zu verständigen
und die Lösung muss sein einzuwirken aus
die Länder die auf die Länder die sie
aus der Verantwortung ziehen dass sie
asylregeln wieder umsetzen voll
inhaltlich umsetzen und nicht dass man
sich die Arbeit muss
deswegen glaube ich darf man in Europa
auch nicht warten bis das letzte Land da
irgendwie mitmacht das ist auch meine
meine Vorstellung wie so ein Ungarn wird
das nicht machen und übrigens Dänemark
auch nicht ja da muss man überhaupt darf
man überhaupt keine Illusion haben aber
was für mich ganz entscheidend ist sie
tun oder aus ihrer Sicht scheint es
überhaupt kein Problem zu sein da muss
ich Ihnen sagen eine überwiegende
Mehrheit in Deutschland hält das für ein
Problem und es gilt übrigens für die
anderen europäischen Länder im Zweifel
sogar noch stärker und wenn ich jetzt
Politiker bin
dann muss ich doch wenn ich den Eindruck
habe und durch den moskopische Zahlen
ist es auch belegt die Menschen die es
für eines der drei zentralen Probleme in
unserem Land halten dann muss ich dieses
Thema doch bearbeiten da muss ich doch
Lösungsvorschläge machen dann kann ich
doch nicht sagen
könnte Auswirkungen haben deswegen rede
ich über dieses Problem nicht und dann
löst sich von alleine diese These halte
ich für falsch ich tu fast nichts anders
als über dieses Thema zu reden aber ich
habe ihn gerade ein ganzes Bündner
Instrumenten skizziert die wir einsetzen
können um mehr unterschiedliche und
passgenaue Zugangswege zu schaffen
das ist ein Problem weil es nicht
geordnet stattfindet nicht kontrolliert
statt Mauern würde ich sagen Management
der ganzen Aktion und das ist ganz
zentrale das passiert derzeit überhaupt
nicht sondern was wir tun ist wir
überlassen tatsächlich das Thema jenen
Kräften die damit Stimmung machen und
Wahlen gewinnen wollen eine Lösung
interessiert
an der Außengrenze werden wir trotz
Management dann diese Boote hätten wir
nehmen mal an wir koordinieren wir haben
Botschaft Asyl das läuft eigentlich
koordiniert strukturiert 400.000 werden
verteilt und dann kommen trotzdem
diejenigen die glauben sie schaffen es
nicht sie aber wissen wenn Sie einmal da
sind dürfen sie bleiben die kommen jetzt
trotzdem mit den Boden an was machen wir
dann da vor Ort was machen wir dann da
ich würde mal damit beginnen geltendes
Recht umzusetzen das passiert derzeit
nicht an den Grenzen nicht mehr illegale
pushbacks durchzuführen die Menschen
nicht auf und dann das ist ein ganz
großer Punkt ist einfach so drüber
hinweg okay
so wie es jetzt geht besagt dass jeder
rechter versöhnprüfung hat weil es ein
individuell Recht ist nein also die
individuellen Gründe werden geprüft in
einem fairen rechtsstaatlichen Verfahren
das ist wirklich ein Griechenland
und was wir auch brauchen
und warum ich bin sehr dafür dass es ein
gemeinsames nämlich nicht nur
gemeinsames europäisches System
sind ein gemeinsames Verfahren damit wir
nicht unterschiedliche 27
unterschiedliche anerkennungsquoten
haben und ablehnungsquoten sondern
gemeinsame und diese Verfahren die kann
man ja in den Außengrenzen dürfen
nein mit Bewegungsfreiheit und dann aber
und daran scheiter das müssen die
Menschen natürlich verteilt werden
da kommt einer an in Lampedusa ich finde
eine gute Idee europäisches Verfahren da
ist ein Beamter nee ich gehe links weil
ich bin jetzt schon auf dem Grund und
Boden da ist das Verfahren geordnet
Management europäisch eigentlich ich
gehe aber links lang und Tschüss genau
das Problem ist dass natürlich derzeit
manche Staaten attraktiver sind für
geflüchtetes andere weil dort die
Rechtsstaatlichkeit gewahrt werden
niemand will in Ungarn bleiben und kann
auch nicht in Ungarn bleiben
auch jetzt Ungarn hat ja und da gibt es
ein gerichtsurteiltes
verstößt mit den asylregeln die dort
gelten gegen geltendes EU-Recht das
heißt da müssen jetzt Sanktionen Folgen
dafür kann man sich auf europäischer
Ebene einsetzen Umgang etwa auch mit den
subventionskultur
für einzusetzen
über ein Land in Europa außer Luxemburg
dass Ihr Modell tatsächlich umsetzen
wird
immer noch nicht verstanden
Griechenland sind rechtsstaatliche
Demokratien sind nicht Ungarn kommen die
Menschen alle an weil sie nur leider an
der EU Außengrenze ihre Staaten haben
und sie sagen keine Zäune keine Festung
wunderbar sind wir alle dafür dann gehen
die rein und sagen hier wäre jetzt das
normale Verfahren ich habe aber
vielleicht keine Chance weil meine Leute
haben mir erzählt du hast keine Chance
dann gehen die links und dann gehen die
dahin wo sie hin wollen wo gehen die
dann hin dann gehen die vielleicht nach
Deutschland weil sie gehört haben dass
man dort selbst wenn man nicht anerkannt
ist gute Leistung bekommt und dann haben
wir das Problem genau nicht gelöst und
haben trotzdem offiziell Management in
meiner Vorstellung werden natürlich viel
weniger über diesen irregulären Weg über
das territorale hast Du recht ankommen
weil ich es skizziert habe wir schaffen
in diversifiziertes System mit vielen
unterschiedlichen Zugangswegen
kontingentlösung ist ein Teil davon also
ja bin ich bei ihnen ich kann ja bis zu
den großen Teil sogar mit mit ihrem
Vorschlag ich würde nur sagen zusätzlich
wie sie richtig gesagt haben
gibt es eine Zahl von der sie sagen
würden in der Forschung ab da wird dann
irgendwann eine Gesellschaft das wird
dann ich glaube das ist ganz schön
schwierig zu quantifizieren weil was wir
schon noch ehrlich ansprechen müssen ist
dass die Fluchtursachen weltweit ja
nicht sinken im Gegenteil sie sind im
steigen und das ist ein ganz großes
Thema es ist teilweise auch mit
verursacht von globalen Norden und wir
haben die richtigen Antwort nicht bin
bei ihnen ja ich schlage nur vor und
deshalb kann ich jetzt nur ansatzweise
skizzieren wir schaffen mehr Regularität
unterschiedliche diversifizierten
keinerlei
keinerlei Begrenzung das sagen sie ja
die Begrenzung ist natürlich schwierig
weil dadurch steht dass Individualrecht
auf Asyl ja genau und das ist
tatsächlich Schwierigkeit ich glaube
aber tatsächlich dass in dem wir auch
mehr und unterschiedlich Formen der
legalen arbeitszuwanderung schaffen dass
dadurch auch Druck aus dem System
genommen wird und was wäre ein riesiger
Vorteil also im Bereich der legalen
arbeitszuwanderung haben wir sicherlich
ein Riesenpotenzial und vor allen Dingen
auch große Notwendigkeiten aber ich
bleibe bei der These qualifizierte
Migration in den Arbeitsmarkt denn um
Erntehelfer geht es im Kern nicht wir
haben in Deutschland 5,5 Millionen
Bürgergeld Empfänger 3,9 Millionen davon
sind im erwerbsfähigen Alter ja das
heißt es gibt genügend Menschen die für
Arbeit grundsätzlich in Frage kommen das
ist also nicht das was man sozusagen
lösen kann über die Migration